this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you everybody for showing up
Jeff thing for the introduction also
thank you for the opportunity to present
some of the work that we're doing in the
gore lab in terms of focusing on abiotic
stress tolerance in crop plants and so
today I'll be talking about how we're
using hi to put plant phenotyping to
look at the genetic basis of heat and
drought stress tolerance in cotton and
so just to give you a brief overview of
how the talk is broken down there's some
background information because outside
of myself and probably Mike and a few
others in our lab I don't think many
people in New York concern themselves
with cotton generally then some basic
plant breeding and remote sensing slides
these aren't to insult anybody's
intelligence just so they're all on the
same page and then we'll actually talk
about the phenotyping experiment
including the platform itself as well as
the experimental design and then finally
how you know we process the data the
analysis that we do and looking at those
results and then finally the next step
in terms of where we're going with this
research and what else we have planned
for the future so although cotton is not
a food crop it single-handedly makes up
one of the three basic requirements for
life which is you know food fiber and
shelter and so no other food crop can
lay claim to pretty much dominating one
of the basic needs of life and because
of that it is the number one fiber crop
in the world it's grown into over 100
countries about 100 million families
incomes depend on this crop so it has a
fairly substantial economic impact
globally the top three producers are
China India and the United States China
and India kind of battle back and forth
right now in terms of who is the number
one producer can see from the figures
it's pretty close the United States is
third so here at home the u.s. crop is
worth about five billion dollars at a
farm gate value this translates into
about 25 billion dollars in terms of
goods and services thats related to
cotton production there are two main
species of cotton aires upland cotton
and that constitutes about ninety-five
percent of the acreage in production
that was what most of us are wearing
currently and then the other variety is
pima and this is more commonly called
Egyptian cotton
or sea island cotton in this bottom
photo you can see that uphams on the
left I don't know come out that long
screen but it tickles upland cotton has
a little bit wider fiber we're pima
cotton is a little bit more
cream-colored what's interesting about
cotton is that it really is a perennial
tree that we cultivate as an annual row
crop and because of that crop management
is very crucial and so the problems of
gye by you know management become pretty
essential in terms of how the crop is
produced with that being said the cotton
fiber itself is pretty interesting the
fact that it's a single cell outgrowth
from the surface of the seed and so what
happens is this you know cell long gates
for a while and then after it reaches us
to find length it puts on cellulose
essentially bulks up at the end of the
season it dries down and a twist and it
forms this helical structure which is
what gives it some mechanical properties
and the other thing that's interesting
is that you know the fiber itself is one
hundred percent pure cellulose so like
all production excuse me all
agricultural production the increasingly
variable weather patterns that we see
and you know the diminishing freshwater
resources that we have occurring put a
great strain on all agricultural systems
and cotton is no less susceptible than
anything else this picture just kind of
epitomizes what the face of you know the
suffering looks like this poor farmer
has just lost his field and as we look
forward to the future though where is
cotton grown in the United States so the
Cotton Belt expands from California up
along the eastern seaboard those that
select region over here in California
those seven counties that produce all
the nations pima cotton the rest of it
is the majority of is upland and a lot
of it comes from Texas exclusively like
the high plains but what's interesting
is where cotton is produced historically
has been threatened by drought so here
is the Drought Monitor map for 2011 this
was a pretty severe drought for Texas it
caused a 2.2 billion dollar economic
loss from state fifty five percent of
the acres planted we're just abandoned
and when we have these high incidences
drought typically what's co-occurring at
this time is high heat and so you know
everybody is aware that this pattern is
you know pretty prevalent throughout the
world and so the global data supports
the same pattern in China in India in
terms of cotton production so the
challenge becomes developing heat and
drought stress tolerant varieties so
that we can maintain sustainable
production well hopefully you know
maximizing our use of the available
water that we do have as well as other
natural resources so plant breeding
really offers the best solution despite
what major seed companies might have you
believe there is no drought gene so
genetically modified approach typically
is not going to work and so plant
breeding is you know the genetic
improvement of plants for human benefit
and the basics of it is we take two
plants that we both have desirable
features we in turn ate them we evaluate
their progeny from the progeny we're
trying to identify the line that has the
most amount of favorable genes from each
parent and in order to do that
evaluation we use two sources of
information we use the genotype which is
its genetic makeup and the phenotype
this is the actual physical appearance
of the plant this is typically what you
eat but in this case it's going to be
what you wear so actual lint yield in
this image you can see starting out with
the wild cotton there's not a lot of
fiber and the actual length of the
fibers is not that long whereas now we
move to cultivated cotton substantially
more fiber and greatly increase fiber
length and so kind of like the tenant of
plant reading is the ability to connect
genotype to phenotype given that if we
understand the underlying genetics of a
trait we better understand the system we
can more effectively manipulate it to
our you know our own will if you want
this case you know producing more lint
fiber and you know any way that we could
understand the system we can speed
things up and develop cultivars more
efficiently currently right now for most
crops it's about a 10 year cycle to go
from across to releasing a commercial
variety so anything we can do to cut
down that time greatly helps us in terms
of meeting climate change as well as
production demands and so kind of
another basic of plant breeding is
it's a numbers game in terms of
releasing new cultivars basically you
know if you cross these parents the more
progeny that you can screen the better
the higher success rate you have of
identifying that one unique individual
that carries the most amount of
favorable genes from each parent in
terms of genetics and actually no
studies of genetics we want to work with
larger populations because that
increases our statistical power to
basically dissect the genetic
architecture this means you know find
the genes the cause of elements that are
giving rise of the phenotype and thereby
you know if we can understand those
processes hopefully we can improve our
breeding methods but given that next
challenge is how do you know how you
manage collecting data on large
populations under actual field
conditions and so in the last 20 years
the bulk of the plant communities effort
has been on developing genotyping
sequencing technology and so on the left
you see this top image is a ABI 377
3,000 of these were running in tandem
for over a year to sequence the human
genome that was in 1997 17 years later
we have one machine one day one genome
so that gives you an idea of how fast
technology improved unfortunately for
plant phenotyping we have not seen that
in 1974 this gentleman is measuring a
cactus with a steel tape measure 40
years later almost a double the only
thing that's improved is we use a
bar-coded measuring tape and this kind
of highlights you know the problems of
field phenotyping and why you know this
new development is needed in terms of
technology to address these issues so
classic fields phenotyping it's time
intensive it just takes getting people
out there to collect the data and
because of this you get a limited amount
of data collected on that constrains
your population size the collective
influences how much data you can
actually collect so typically just like
single time point also there is the
issue of quality in the public sector
most of data being collected these large
field trials is by undergraduates that
have little to no investment in the
project they're working on so that's
always an issue trait bias typical
you're out there you want to score
easily identifiable traits like plant
height flowering date things that don't
take long for you to work with you can
just look at the actual plot and assess
its score and all these things give rise
of the fact that classic fields
phenotyping is expensive so what's
coming up is this hike of a plant
phenotyping basically the combination of
sensors and vehicles to collect data
rapidly in the same experimental fields
this enables us to work with larger
populations like we already talked about
in terms of increasing statistical power
but more importantly it provides us a
longitudinal assessment of the phenotype
instead of these single time point
estimates we actually get to see how the
crop is developing along with the season
and this allows us to look at trait
development versus the cumulative
effects like yield at the end of the
season you measure yield and basically
you're capturing all the genetics have
taken place over the course of that
plants lifetime whereas if we can sample
it at different points along the way we
can maybe you know tease apart what's
occurring at each stage also allows us
to look at traits in relation to their
environment plants or sessle organisms
so they can't get up and leave they
don't like the conditions so this gives
us a way to assess how they are
interacting with their environment and I
would say it's lower cost because
obviously there is some initial
investment in terms of the sensor
platforms and getting them to work once
you have that up and running it's fairly
easy to go through and collect data so
kind of the fundamentals basically we're
relying on proximal sensing which is an
applied form of remote sensing basically
it's just we're taking these
measurements and close proximity to the
plant using cameras heard of
multispectral hyperspectral regular RGB
cameras and basically we're trying to do
is quantify the interaction
electromagnetic radiation with the plant
canopy and so on the right-hand side you
see the figure that I'm sure most of you
are common or aware of basically you
know the reflectance of the different
wavelengths that plant reflects back and
so it's this combination of non-contact
measurements and vehicles that permit
the rapid and frequent collection of
data throughout the season and so for
most of us probably aware of normalized
difference vegetation index
is a classic you know high-throughput
phenotyping technique that's used and so
moving forward here's the actual
experiment that was conducted in Arizona
the goal of this was to understand the
genetic basis of abiotic stress
tolerance and cotton here is the current
version of the phenotyping platform
that's being used you can see on the
front is where you have your sensors
arrayed it has now been outfitted with
an AC unit not for the driver it
actually puts a AC air out to the
sensors to keep them cool it now has an
onboard small supercomputer for
processing data and so briefly before we
start that it's the idea of quantifying
stress response the sensors that we have
don't measure the stress itself it
measures how the plot plant responds and
so typically what we do is work with
multiple sensors that have overlap and
so we'll look at canopy traits like
canopy temperature which gives us an
idea of plant water relations and ndvi
in this case we're using it to quantify
wilting or how the actual plant
geometries changing as a day progresses
having overlap is critical because it's
like when you go to the doctor what's
the first thing they do they take your
temperature and all that tells you is
whether or not you're sick doesn't tell
you what you're suffering from right and
so it's kind of the same thing where if
we just collected ndvi and saw that well
k the plants wilting well plants can
wilt from drought stress but they can
also wilt from cold stress so if you
don't have the company you know canopy
temperature data you can't really be
certain what response you're measuring
with these sensors and so this is kind
of the key thing is about knowing what
stresses are being applied to the plant
and understanding what it is you're
measuring in terms of a response and so
for our experiment this was conducted in
central Arizona clear skies very limited
rainfall extremely high temperatures on
their right here's a graph of the daily
highs and low temperatures with the red
line at 32 degrees C temperatures above
this sharply decrease lint yields of the
240 days shown up here only 10 of those
days did not exceed that threshold so
basically it was pretty consistent high
heat stress we also use to ear
asian treatments a water limited and a
well-watered basically these were a dry
to wet the driving you know water was
replenished at fifty percent of daily
evapotranspiration rate versus a hundred
percent this was administered using
subsurface irrigation so this gave us a
really precise way to control how much
water the plants are actually able to
access and finally the stress was
initiated flowering imposing drought
stress before flowering typically the
only thing you'll find out as it plants
the flower early typically yield better
it's one of the main drought voyance
mechanism that all plants employ and so
basically the take-home is is that this
experimental design location provided us
consistent heat and drought stress and
so we know why the plants were actually
showing the symptoms and the signs of
the suffering that they were a little
bit more about the experiment you can
see in the photo here is the actual
field itself about 110 meters long the
circled I guess square around the plots
these are the actual feel that we use
it's 95 by parental upland cotton lines
and the canopy traits that we're
measuring with our high pivot
phenotyping platform our canopy
temperature height ndvi and leaf area
index some of the physiological traits
that we're also measuring is eps isaac
acid content in carbon isotope
discrimination these are two hallmark
traits that are typically collected in
terms of understanding abiotic stress
tolerance physiology additionally we
collected agronomic traits including
fiber quality excuse me lint healed on
both sides and then fiber quality traits
like length strength and fineness and
then the additional set of data we
collected was this actual ioan omics
panel so here is the actual platform
that was used to collect the data it's a
high-clearance tractor that's been
retrofitted with these set of sensors
and so the one that majority of you may
be common with is the crop circle it's
an active multispectral crop canopy
sensor and so we have four of these
arranged in a row and basically each row
underneath here as a unique genotype the
other one we had was an IRT and infrared
thermometer collecting our canopy
temperature data
and then finally a altra sonic
transducer basically a sonar thats
collecting plant height and the key
piece of equipment that really ties us
together is having a GPS system that has
a high level precision so we use an rtk
GPS so your standard GPS has a precision
of about three feet and given that these
rows are closer than three feet it
wouldn't allow us the resolution
actually tie back the data points to the
specific genotypes this rtk system gives
you sub centimeter level precision and
so that's what enables us to make sure
that the data Maps up to the right
plants in the field and then finally
there's data loggers to collect the data
put the timestamp on there as well as
geo locate geolocation position points
and it is fairly fast it could collect
all the data on that boxed area within
here it could collect all these readings
in about 30 minutes and so once we
collect the data becomes a question of
you know the analysis pipeline of what
do you actually do with it now and so
now walk you to about how we took the
raw data and actually do the genetic
analysis so here is the ogio process
canopy temperature data and blue
indicates cooler to canopy temperatures
green indicates warmer so the
well-watered versus the water limited
it's about a three to 10 degree
difference but the first thing that
comes a parent is the resolution that we
have so each circle represents one data
point and within this you can begin to
see the variation between genotypes you
can even start to see variation within
the field itself you'll notice down here
on this east end of the field there's a
little bit cooler canopy temperatures
than the west end and this is a dry
treatment and this is attributable to
high clay content clay holds onto water
obviously better and so the plants had a
little bit more water to work with in
terms of the actual data quality control
it's a lengthy process just like in any
analysis this is where most of your time
is spent by the other thing is a gene
dealing with these change
conditions as you're collecting the data
so on this image is graph you'll see
from 732 8 just the ambient temperature
increases 6 degrees in that half hour if
you don't correct for this basically
your canopy temperature data will tell
you nothing and so the method of how you
deal with that you know we use analysis
of covariance we also use time as a
random factor to see how they compared
we treated time as a random factor it
did a good job of handling this but it
also handled sensor variation the
sensors do vary in terms of their
temperature and that affects our
measurement accuracy and then finally
you know plotting some of the data to
make sure that there's some issues that
can always arise like in this case the
sonar was miscalibrated and our plants
are about a half a meter taller than
they should have been so it's just kind
of these quality control issues that you
need to go through so once we have that
all processed we move on to the actual
you know we estimate the line values so
for canopy temperature here the biggest
thing you see obviously is the
difference between the two treatments
it's about 10 degrees but within that
you see you know in the water limited
you see there's a fair amount of
variation in terms of the line values
for canopy temperature and so one of the
basics of plant breeding is that you
have to read to requirements there has
to be variation for the trait and that
variation has to be heritable and what
that means is that the variation you're
seeing is controlled by actual genes and
not just the environment and so
heritability is on a scale of 0 to 10
means that the environment is driving
all the variation that you're seeing one
means that it's all due to genetics and
so in this case we have fairly high
estimates of heritability meaning you
know the genetics is controlling a
canopy temperature trait given this you
can also see we have here are the
parents of the population and this is
the idea of transgressive variation in
fact that you know progeny some of these
lines do actually get more favorable
genes from either parents and therefore
they outperform either parent so this is
what we're looking for in terms of
developing new varieties as varieties
that have these you know
canopy temperature properties in terms
of being able to stay cooler but what's
really cool it really has not been done
before is measuring this in terms of
time and so here we have four time
points across the day 7 10 1 and 3 p.m.
and we can see there's a range of
responses in terms of the actual canopy
traits so down here for canopy
temperature excuse me canopy height it
responds pretty much just like you would
think the plants don't get taller or
shrink over the course of the day the
difference you see is do the irrigation
treatments which makes sense that stress
plants just aren't as fit as you know
the ones that have access to water as we
move up we see that LA I has a slight
decrease across the day as the plant
begins to wilt but finally we move up to
ndvi and canopy temperature you'll see
then nvv I seven things start out okay
in the morning they start to go downhill
by about ten o'clock and then from 10 to
1 p.m. this is the peak heat stress of
the day this is when the plants are not
happy and you see the most amount of
wilting occurring and then by 1pm the
plants are kind of cooked and they don't
really recover until night canopy
temperature canopy temperature is the
same story basically it starts out from
7am there's a linear progression until
1pm but the plants that have access to
water you know don't suffer nearly as
bad and by 1pm again you're looking at
about a 10 degree difference between the
two treatments and so this just shows us
that the canopy temperature and ndvi are
extremely responsive traits in terms of
the soil moisture environment that
they're in as well as the actual air
temperature and so this is kind of what
we're after in terms of you know when we
do our genetic analysis we're using
these four time points to try and
determine what genes are driving this
response in terms of you know response
to the environment as it progresses
across the day and so finally you know
as we move forward I just want to focus
on canopy temperature here so that was
just over the course of one day but do
we see that same effects over the entire
season and sure enough well again we
look at those same four time points
across the top and then on the bottom
here is the actual canopy temperature
values
and then the days of the season along he
left hand access we see that shirt off
this dynamic response of cotton to you
know increased temperature and
irrigation regime is consistent and I've
listed the plant developmental stages on
the left hand side as well basically to
highlight that this response is
consistent across you know the plants
development which is good for us moving
forward if we look at the actual canopy
temperature measurements this is for
2011 something that's kind of cool that
came out of this was when we look within
these developmental stages we see the
correlation between the canopy
temperature readings are more correlated
with in a gross stage than a crossed and
what this is suggesting to us is that
these sensors are actually capturing
some true biological signal and more so
it's telling us that you know this is
responsive canopy temperature is dynamic
and it's dynamic not only in the sense
of across a day across the season but
even appears be dynamic across the
growth stages but furthermore what this
really provides impetus for is that the
fact that single point time excuse me
single time point phenotyping just isn't
going to cut it in terms of revealing
what's happening in terms of the plants
life cycle this would be akin to just
taking a still snapshot versus you know
with HTTP we're using essentially a
video to capture everything that's
occurring across the season and this is
giving us a more detailed information in
terms of how plants are responding and
so we actually do the genetic analysis
we use this technique called
quantitative trait loci mapping I don't
know if some of you may be familiar with
it basically we're taking two parents
we're crossing them you'll see the two
parents vary in their genotype their
offspring has fifty percent contribution
from each one after things go through a
round of recombination their chromosomes
get broken up and what we're doing is
we're using the genetic markers to
actually capture these recombination
events and this is what allows us to
identify these genomic intervals that
contain genes that could you know be
impacting the phenotype we're observing
so in this case there's a QTL interval
of you know 20 centons
and this could contain 200 or more genes
but this is the basic technique that
we're applying to our data moving
forward this is how it the results
panned out in our study I realized this
graph is probably hard to read
especially because it's been reduced in
size for the presentation on the top we
have the dry and the wet exceed on the
bottom is wet treatment on this
right-hand access we have the three
different years 2010 11 and 12 on the
left-hand side or again the days within
that season and what we're trying to
identify our you know QTL that impact
canopy temperature so if it's red that
means it causes the canopy temperature
to increase whereas if it's blue this q
tal vez genomic interval actually causes
the canopy temperature to decrease and
so the interesting result for us was the
fact that we were able to identify QTL
that were expressed in a temporal basis
this kind of fits with what we would all
expect that you know genes aren't turned
on the whole time through the whole
season that there's this temporal
component to it and nobody had really
ever shown this in terms of actually you
know field-based phenotyping it's been
done with growth chambers but to
actually see this result with field
based data is extremely exciting but as
we move forward I think we all know we
live in an age we're generating data is
easy it's cheap it's not really an issue
at this point now the point is you know
does this data actually mean anything
and so we took our canopy temperature
results and we also took the results
from doing the QTL mapping for these
other physiological traits like eps
isaac acid content and carbon isotope
discrimination and we overlaid those
results they co-located the exact same
region and then luckily enough for me I
finished these analysis probably like an
April and about a week later the cotton
genome was published and so I'd rather
be lucky than good and then so we took
these QTL intervals and blasted them
against the actual genome sequence and
we found these candidate genes so for
this was a cute kale for carbon isotope
discrimination there was only for
Jesus's interval and one of them was a
drought response of family protein
looking at the other literature it fit
quite nicely with the response we're
seeing in terms of water regulation the
other one this qql on this side was
identified for seismic acid content and
again when we did the blast search
against the genome the candidate gene
that we identify was a navy a response
binding element factor and so this is
exactly what we want to see because it
lets us know that our fancy platform is
out there collecting all this data it's
actually collecting something real and
that there's really no jeans driving the
phenotype that we're seeing and that our
platform is able to capture that no
surprise that increased leaf
transpiration contributes to you know
higher lint yield under drought stress
and this is a repeatable pattern across
the different years these are just three
time points from each respective year
seems a fairly consistent pattern but
just to note that you only see this
response if there's actually available
soil water if there's no water in the
soil plants just can't do anything but
what's interesting is the distribution
so these lines out here these are your
water spenders and these guys up here
are your water savers basically the idea
is that some genotypes recognize that I
will always have water therefore i'm
just going to keep transpiring no matter
what the actual conditions are whereas
these guys up here they're a little bit
more conservative they're say no I'm
going to hang on to my water because I
don't know what's going to happen in the
future so I don't want to burn through
all of it and then not have any and so
the idea is you know do you breed for
water you should water use efficiency or
the idea of efficient use of water and
so that is just kind of a tool to help
discern what it is you want to target
obviously c4 plants are different than
c3 and how that impacts water use
efficiency the other thing that was
interesting was a relation between
canopy temperature and lint yield and we
did the correlation analysis we saw that
canopy temperature was most correlated
with yield during flowering this isn't
surprising flowering during cotton
development is pretty critical time high
heat causes floral abnormalities
use palm sterility floral abscission and
basically if you don't have a flower
there's no way you can develop a Cotton
Bowl there's no way you can generate any
yield we saw the same thing for both
sides and canopy temperature except that
both sides is most correlated during the
middle of the season which corresponds
the development and fill so using this
type of information we're hoping we can
move forward and develop more predictive
models of actually you know yield using
this type of data some continuing work
that we have with the collaborators
still there is using lidar imaging so
this is lidar is an instrument that
basically emits a late light beam and
measures their time it takes for that
light to get reflected back and so it
basically creates like a 3d image and so
here is an image of one of those entire
blocks of our experiment and so you can
kind of begin to see the different rows
within but as we zoom in here's a side
profile the foliated plants and the key
is that they have to be the foliated
because the light can't go through the
leaves you begin to see the basic
structure of the cotton plants and so
these you know clouds of points this
would actually be a Cotton Bowl if we
zoom in one more level you can actually
see the actual individual plants and
what's really interesting to us is the
fact that you can know map where these
cotton bolls are at in terms of their
location on the plant as well as get
some Kuip of estimate of their size and
so this is the type of you know
technology moving forward to to better
understand Cotton's response to heat and
drought stress and undoubtedly other
crops as well so just kind of a summary
on this part of the experiment basically
was the development and deployment of
this high school phenotyping platform
and the ability to collect data
throughout the season on multiple times
during the day gave us a way to study
and quantified I am across parts under
contrasting irrigation regime regimes
and basically allowing us to connect the
physiology and plant development to the
genetics that we're really targeting and
the most exciting thing was this
identification of temporally express QTL
patterns in terms of seeing that yes QTL
you know they're not on all the time
and they respond to their environment as
well as the plant developmental stage so
in terms of our next steps about where
we go from here and working with abiotic
stress tolerance its kind of
understanding this equation phenotype is
a component of genotype environment and
their interaction so at this point we're
really good at getting the genotype data
we're improving on getting the phenotype
data but it's kind of understanding the
idea of how genotypes interact with
their environment and so in terms of
quantifying the environment you know
atmospheric conditions we're pretty good
at collecting weather data soil
conditions in the plant breeding world
we really don't incorporate these much
into what we do and so looking going
forward in terms of understanding gene
type by environment interaction what we
typically do now is we grow these lines
out at numerous locations and
essentially am estimate a deviation from
an overall mean it's not a very precise
method and so our current phenotyping
technology really only tells half the
story because we only can see no type
the top half the plant right everything
is below ground we can't see infield
root phenotyping is just in its infancy
and there's really no viable technology
out there to get that kind of
information and so the question is we
want to know is you know how do plants
interact with their soil environment
since this is kind of you know where
they extract their nutrients where
they're getting their waters from so
it's a very key component and basically
if we can understand these g by e
components we can capitalize on its
effect because genotype environment
interaction is not a you know linear
response it's more of a multiplicative
where you can get greater increases in
yields if we can capitalize on specific
environments and so to do that the
challenge becomes developing these
predictive models of plant performance
and so one approach that we're taking to
this is using ion omics basically every
component of the cell contains elements
and these elements are involved from
everything from electro chemical balance
you know water regulation osmoregulation
biochemical reactions structural
components they
form complex interactions there's all
all sorts of you know overlap between
the different networks in terms of ion
transporters that can transport both
types of ions but those ions are
selectively transported based on local
ph and so what's exciting for us though
is that the change in elemental
composition can be influenced by in this
case abiotic stress or droughts soil
composition plant morphology as well as
developmental stage of the plant and so
we're hoping to do is kind of capitalize
on this abiotic stress and down here at
the bottom is a table of periodic
elements and those ones and the gold
boxes are the essential elements for
plant growth these are the ones that we
are collecting data on in our eye on
Alex panel the purple ones are
non-essential trace elements what they
do give us an idea of what's occurring
in the actual soil environment and so
here's this a brief rundown of the
pipeline basically the plants are
growing in the field we get the mature
seeds they're putting you know these
plastic 48 well Trey's there's a robot
that puts them into these test tubes
they're dissolved in acid they go
through looks like an incubation step
then you have your technician Greg
Ziggler bless his heart he fights them
out and then he runs them for you on the
icp-ms which is high on coupled plasma
mass spectrometer and so we're hoping to
get to is understanding the physiology
as it relates to genotype by environment
interactions and we're using see
dynamics to do this and so you know the
question is how does cotton change its
you know uptake of elements from the
soil in response to abiotic stress and
this could really help us you know
understand the environmental impacts of
physiology and also maybe potentially
provide us with some type of predictive
tool to understand which those genotypes
are better able to cope with stress and
so in these by plots of the elements
down here you can see that strontium and
calcium don't really change from the
well water to the water limited
treatments but if you look at cadmium it
changes quite a bit in relation to the
other elements so this would be
something we'd be looking for in terms
of maybe some type of on fuel
a biomarker to indicate you know abiotic
stress tolerance how plant you could use
CAD iam in order to cope with heat and
drought extending this work a little bit
further this is a very Oh gram of the
calcium ions in the seed after
correcting for the different irrigation
treatment effects as well as spatial
effects of the field and you can see on
this east end of the field again you
have these high residuals and so the
idea is you know we could use statistics
we can fit polynomials we can handle
this in a statistical way but perhaps we
should think about it by incorporating
information about the actual environment
that's occurring where these plants are
being growing and so on the left we have
these am 38 readings basically giving
this idea of the soil texture and
basically we see down here you know this
area of the field has a high clay
content and so and then if we look on
this one this is the actual creating
calcium content at a depth of 60
centimeters and we back up I apologize
we also collected I anomic data on the
soil itself not just the seeds and the
depths are there's five depths ranging
up to 120 centimeters and so that's kind
of the data we're using to model the
calcium content within the field and so
we can see the type of spatial
variability with respect calcium and so
we're trying to do as we move forward as
incorporate these environmental
parameters into our models in terms of
understanding how cotton or quite
frankly any planet for that matter is
you know using its environment to deal
with heat and drought and how these all
these components fit together instead of
just treating the environment as maybe
you know in a statistical method and so
moving forward it's kind of idea of
integration of information crop growth
is not an additive process but all of
our models treat it that way and so
really what we're trying to move forward
to is you know utilizing crop growth
models because they represent a
functional relationship between plant
physiology in the environment and how
that actually impacts the overall
phenotype and so currently we're really
good at these two aspects in terms of
quantifying the environment and seeing
the actual final phenotype at the end
but what happens in between we're not so
good at and so one way we could address
this is with high throughput phenotyping
is we can actually estimate these growth
parameters like radiation use efficiency
leaf initiation rate as well as lief
appearance rate and what we would like
to move forward to is actually using
these crop growth models to extract the
parameters these growth parameters and
use those of the new phenotypes they
have some interesting properties they
show less genotype by environment
interaction they typically have higher
heritabilities than the traits being
measured themselves so from analysis
standpoint they have some desirable
features but basically we like to move
forward in terms of developing these
genotypic growth curves this would
permit QTL mapping on a continuous basis
so you know the data we have will just
have these select time points along the
curve where now we can fill in the
entirety of it and use that type of
information for the QTL mapping to
identify the genes that are driving the
phenotypes and ultimately moving forward
to incorporating all this information to
understand how the components relate so
down here we have our environment in
terms of precipitation and most growing
regions in North America it's wetter in
the beginning of the season and gets
drier at the end well as well as
temperature it stays cooler than peaks
in the middle of the summer and then
tapers off and what we're trying to do
you know is understand QTL expression
whether that cute tail expression is
favorable increases or decreases and
basically what we're trying to do is
connect all this together in relation
and develop these genotype growth curves
and if we can do this and we can
understand that some poral patterns of
gene expression in relation to their
environment we have a chance to really
optimize genotypes for even seasonal
precipitation patterns peak heat stress
and maturation time and so pull oh yeah
and so that's kind of where we're moving
forward to so just some overall
conclusions I hide through the
phenotyping will undoubtedly you know
change the way we plan
it's a very valuable tool in terms of
like letting us look at plant
development and trade expression and a
new way and but more or less it allows
us to peek in and like this idea of not
just a static time point of just you
know taking these snapshots we actually
get to see the trig develop how the
plant responds to environment and how
the actual phenotype is form something
that's not really been done before and
so if we can successfully you know
integrate all this information hopefully
will help you know breeding for precise
environments you know at the bottom line
we're trying to optimize varieties to
help farmers because farming is an
extremely risky business since most of
us are in this room I don't think we
make our income on it it's very you know
the profit margins are thin and anything
we can do to help i think is worth wild
and I think this offers a very
sustainable solution and finally no
addressing issues of climate change and
how our plants are able to cope with
that stress in terms of people i mean
there's always a ton of people to thank
on a project of the size so Mike the
core lab member is Tim all the people at
usda-ars over this experiment was
conducted its including what university
of arizona as well as new mexico state
and university of illinois and with that
I would thank you for your time and
attention and welcome any questions so
this is just a by plot in terms of how
the traits are related in terms of their
variance so the angle between them is
how their correlation value in the
length of the vector is how much
variation there is so I can't really
tell you in terms of how that changes i
can only tell you how it changed
relative to the other elements being
analyzed i haven't seen any type of ir
sensors that would correlate with the I
nomics data but in terms of what you're
saying interpret you know incorporating
that time element I mean we can do the I
omics on leaf samples I think I want to
speak out of turn your mic what I think
one of the reason we did on the seat is
for cost reasons because if we were to
do it across the entire season or you
know regular intervals I don't know how
much that would cost yeah but yeah I
mean it would be ideal to find something
you know some type of camera that could
tell us the same information is doing
the actual I gnomic analysis basically
do extensive outlier remover removal
process because we're collecting so much
data like you said not all of its good
and so we do is we fit like a linear
mixed model we used to die salute of
residuals to remove those data points
that are obviously flawed I mean like
worth ndvi if you get anything below
point three automatically you're
thinking that's ground so those get
thrown out with a canopy temperature I
mean you would see values of like 60
degrees c and so you're like well that's
obviously not the plant because it would
literally be on fire probably but no
it's like it's a good question i mean
because you have to get rid of that data
it's not all good oh it's one of the
things for the groups in australia the
one of the things they look at is actual
route angle because I'm announced me
sorghum is really good at stealing water
from its neighbors and at first it goes
lateral and then it goes down and so
that's kind of the same type of question
you know how does how does the genotype
what's the response that it's using to
do that it's like you're suggesting I
mean if we could figure out the actual
growth parameter that would give us an
idea of how is accessing its water and
its nutrients and again like we can
combine that type of information with
the soil profile that gives us a better
idea all right with that I think free
time this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu